hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the first
round of the Fay Grand swis that just
started and um it's not just a great
tournament but it's also a very
important one for the Fay World Chess
Championship cycle uh the uh winner and
the runnerup will get their spots in the
Fay candidates tournament
2024 and we'll be joining some of the
players who have already qualified you
know that Yanni pishi has qualified
already as he played the World Chess
Championship match against ding Len he
lost and then he gets um seeded right
into the next cycle of the uh candidates
uh tournament and then you have the top
three finishers of the um Chess World
Cup 2023 which are Magnus Carlson of
course but he will not be playing maybe
he will still who knows he says he's not
going to probably he won't but he still
might uh pranda also qualified and
Fabiano corana qualified and Nish abasov
if Magnus Carlson will not play so we
already know four players of the Fe
candid tournament that will be playing
uh we need four more and those four more
will be decided the top two finishers in
the FED Grand swis tournament the
tournament that we are now covering uh
the winner of the 2023 fed circuit and
of course the highest rating for January
2024 there are a couple of candidates
that might get this position ala and
Hikaru are very very close to getting
that and as they are both playing in
this tournament should be very
interesting so the FED Grand swis 2023 a
few words before we actually check out
the game and it is quite a nice one I
thought about covering a few others but
I thought you guys will enjoy this one
the most uh it's taking place from
October 25th to November 11th on the
aisle of men uh in the UK it's an 11
round Swiss tournament that will deter
two places for the 2024 candidates uh uh
that will decide the Challenger of
course the winner of the candidates
tournament will challenge the world
classical chess champion ding Len if he
decides to play as he still has he he
has yet to play a game after becoming
world champion and the total price fund
is
$460,000 with $80,000 being for first
place now the time format we have the
time control of 100 minutes for 40 moves
followed by 50 minutes for the next 20
moves Then followed by 15 minutes for
the rest of the game with a 30 seconds
increment starting from move one so a
little bit about the tournament before
we actually check it out something I
often like to do uh when showing the
first game from the tournament but we
are not going to do that for the other
games of the tournament now let's check
it out quite a beauty you guys will
enjoy this one sang Shuda
faces Grand Master from Iran puya idani
uh let's check it out Duda with the
white pieces opens with Pon to C4 he
goes for the English opening we have
Pawn to E6 the ainur defense Knight to
C3 and pawn to D5 Duda plays Pawn to D4
and transposes into the uh the Queen's
Knight variation of the Queen's Gambit
declined uh and here we have Pawn to H6
this is a very very rare move um maybe
like the 10th most popular continuation
in this particular setup but it has been
played by some very very strong players
um even by Magnus Carlson himself he
played against Tamor rajabov in 2021 FTX
crypto cup and he even defeated rajabu
with this H6 move so we have Knight to
F3 Knight to F6 and now sorry Knight to
F6 and Bishop to F4 we have Bishop to E6
and now Bishop captures on D6 uh now
Magnus also had this position with black
against the ding Len in the Skilling
open but that game ended in a draw then
continued with Pawn to E3 but here we
have captures on D6 with have Queen
captures and now Pawn to C5 grabbing
more space in the um not in the center
but um uh you know deciding not to to
fight for the central control anymore
and now you are advancing the pawn to C5
and now you know that B4 A4 B5 are
coming so preparing a minority attack
here Queen to E7 and now Pawn to E3 uh
we have castles and pawn to B4 now so
this has all been played before still
nothing new and there is a game uh
Martin locander played against Lucas F
forest in bundes Lia uh last year and uh
Lucas F Forest won that game he played
Ponto A6 but here we have Pon to C6 and
it is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game and this is where
our game uh basically begin skins we
have Bishop to E2 continuing development
preparing to Castle Pawn to A6 now we
have castles Knight B to D7 and pawn to
A4 so of course you know that B5 is
coming at some point uh we have Pawn to
E5 and now Queen to C2 gaining more
control over the E4 Square we have Pawn
to E4 chasing away the Knight Knight to
D2 and now Knight to H7 so Duda is
obviously playing on the queen side and
poya is preparing F5 F4 and G G5 G4 he
wants to attack the white king with some
Pawn pushes on the king side so Pawn to
B5 and pawn to F5 we have a very nice
race here Knight to B3 and pawn to A5
now uh saying that okay you could
Advance the pawn that's not really
spectacular capturing isn't really doing
anything but Duda says okay you played
A5 it's defended by The Rook but my
knight is already attacking and let's
prepare a nice Discovery here Queen to
D2 now puts pressure on that A5 Pawn and
look at what happens Pawn to G5 and Duda
now goes for it here puya uh sort of
gives Duda a deadly d uh because you
know that Knight captures on A5 is
happening Rook captures and then all
sorts of nasty discoveries are possible
like Knight captures on D5 going after
the queen and the Rook uh and well of
course it does require you to look very
very far into the future if you can
actually pull this off uh it is by far
the best move and Duda plays at Knight
captures on A5 and okay Rook captures
Knight captures on D5 attacks the queen
so you have to react C captures and
queen captures on A5 so okay two pieces
for The Rook but look at this massive
Pawn chain here of course now the queen
will move and then the a pawn will March
forward you know that Duda now will get
a pass Pawn question is are his Queen
side pawns faster than pua's Kings side
pawns so let's see Knight D2 F6 uh Queen
to B6 preparing to start advancing pawns
we have Pawn to F4 and Pawn to A5 we
have Pawn to F3 uh and G captures an F3
we have Bishop to H3 now going after the
Rook here and um if uh Pua can get two
moves in let's say queen to D7 followed
by Queen to G4 if this um tension here
is resolved then he's very very close to
actually checkmating Yang shishov so
Pawn to A6 and now e captures on F3 H if
you go for the Rook with Bishop captures
on F1 after Bishop captures there's
really no good way to continue the
attack like e captures on F3 uh
nothing's happening a captures on B7
already B8 is being threatened and
there's no no way to reach that um white
king so instead after A6 we have e
captures on F3 first and now Bishop
captures on F3 and now B captures on A6
now uh the reason uh you can't go for
the white King right away because you're
always behind them at least a move for
example a captur some B
Rook captures on F3 you can even pick up
this uh Bishop here uh White gets a
queen into the game with check and after
you block there's just no good way to
continue Rook to A7 and if you could get
your queen to G4 sure but you just can't
so instead after Bishop captures on F3
first B captures on A6 now comes B
captures on A6 and now Pawn to G4
attacking the bishop here and okay uh
you probably are wondering why not just
try to get our Queen into the game
somehow Queen D7 maybe Queen to F5 go
after the bishop uh it U it it actually
is the best move but it still doesn't
work white has this beautiful queen to
B3 move and now after Queen to F5
attacking the bishop there's this a very
annoying E4 move you defend the bishop
you attack the black queen uh the D Pawn
is pinned you cannot capture with the
pawn and if you play Knight captures on
e4 then Bishop captures and now once you
capture or you don't have to capture you
can give a check then just King moves
and the bishop is still guarding this
entire diagonal uh you will play Queen
captures on e4 but now Queen captures on
H3 and you just uh I mean you have two
Rooks against the rook and the Knight
and the past a pawn is still marching
forward there's no way to actually reach
the white king here uh but yes Queen to
D7 is the most resilient way to play
this G4 was played uh and while this is
not as um maybe objectively precise as
Queen to D7 it will require do that uh
make the only only moves that will win
him the game he plays Queen to B7 Queen
to E6 and now feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only move that
wins the game for Yang shishto while I
give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this uh elusive idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is best Bishop to H1 this is the only
move that wins you might think okay
isn't Bishop to G2 the same no it isn't
because we just trade and after captures
captures there's Queen E4 check and
after King G1 already Knight to G5 and
once Knight to H3 lands that is game
over so this will lose you the game uh
instead Bishop to H1 was played and now
with the control of this diagonal there
is no way for for uh the queen or any of
the pieces to reach the the white king
So Knight to G5 trying to get them
closer but now Pawn to A7 do that one
just enough time to accomplish this
Knight to F3 check but now he can give
up the bishop Bishop captures on F3 G
captures and now again only one move for
Duda wins the game feel free to pause
the video and win it for the second time
because sometimes it's not enough to win
the game once sometimes you have to win
it more than once in a single game so
have at it while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always looking
for fine ways to sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Queen to be8 it's
not really a queen sacrifice because you
also will get another queen into the
game uh but uh it was important to do it
this way uh because okay we're not just
going for the Rook we're also preparing
Queen back to G3 because that's our only
defense against Queen to G4 but it's
it's important to play this and not this
if you play Queen to C7 then Queen to G4
uh will be a problem but look at this
first Knight E4 and now you might think
is the same okay we bring a Queen into
the game now Queen G6 with check and now
after you block now the Knight simply
captures Queen Knight captures H
captures Rook captures on A8 and uh it
will be enough for a draw this comes
with checking F7 Rook F to A1 and the
two Rooks against the the black king on
an open border will be suff ient for a
draw however after Queen to B8 now this
also comes with a threat of Queen
captures on f8 and then we bring another
queen into the game with Tempo and now
black is simply not in time now if you
try the same idea Knight E4 will simply
capture on f8 and AF King captures A8
Queen and after well if the king moves
then you go after the king and then you
win the black queen or you play sorry
you play Queen to d8 and now you simply
trade doesn't really matter captures
captures and now Rook F to B1 the two
Rooks will of course be stronger than a
bishop and the Knight so instead after
this um exchange after Queen to B8
Bishop captures on F1 was played and
here Duda just played A8 Queen uh and it
was in this position on move 32 that um
puani resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so quite
quite a position not something you see
every day uh the queen almost having
access to Checkmate but not really this
queen to G3 move always blocking uh
having the two queens The Rook on A1 uh
basically one it's the only way to
continue like if Queen G4 you're going
to block and now you're going to win the
the queen on A8 but it doesn't matter
Rook captures with check and after King
F7 you will trade queens and after
Knight captures yes you have a bishop
and Knight for a rook but only for one
move because King captures on F1 and
that's it now The Rook will defeat a
knight very easily and for those of you
who like it when I sort of finish the
game Knight captures let's say King G1
Knight G4 uh C6 C7 C8 that's it there's
no way to defend this with black and of
course there it would be pointless to
try so yeah very very impressive by Yang
shishto only 32 moves to finish a
classical game like this very very wild
stuff and it always is when you get
these um positions where where B4 is
played uh again I have to say B4 such a
strong move if you can get those pawns
marching up the board a minority attack
is always always very very dangerous uh
so yeah very nicely done by Yang chisto
I said also was looking into some other
games on board one Fabiano corana faced
um even was also a very uh fine Sicilian
game but I thought you guys would enjoy
this one the most and some of the games
are still being played so if you have a
favorite use hashtag suggestion as usual
and I will very happily go over your
suggestion uh so yeah uh that's the game
and a little bit of extra info about the
tournament hope you enjoyed it and that
you've you were able to solve both pause
the video moments which I'm sure you
were as you all are amazing players uh I
would to thank gumati Mery an anonymous
person Daniel Taylor Marbach emiry and
grid worlds logical letters for iOS for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and also
covering the games of the FED Grand
Swiss until it finishes uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest to your
day